I'm Callie Shaw he's the star of around
the horn and Dallas Morning News
columnist and he joins us on the program
good morning Tim how are you I'm just
getting my radio makeup on I'm ready to
go how do you love you how's your Harrod
yeah hairs a little I've got radio hair
right now for sure we'll have to work on
that you have some of the great hair on
TV you really do it's it's not bad I'll
be honest preferred age and you know you
know it's not Brandel Chamblee but it's
pretty good all right the reason I
wanted to have you on is the dak
Prescott situation and the report
yesterday that the Cowboys could be
looking at paying him thirty million
dollars a year is he if he was on the
open market
what would dak Prescott be worth in your
opinion I'd say that's a great question
and I think the answer is less than that
that would be what the Cowboys if they
really had the will say courage to let
him test the open market they can find
out and but but they never handled Romo
that way they always paid or overpaid
him before they needed to and and at
least from what Jerry Jones says they
seemed fine doing him a dak but to
answer your question I mean I don't
think there would be somebody out there
there surely our teams that like him but
I don't think he's the kind of guy you
would say man if we had him he would
take our team to a new level I think you
see him as a guy who when he has good
people around him he's kind of got a
winner's mentality and his great leader
and he'll run for a first down when he
can't throw for one he like against
Seattle but I don't think thirty million
would be the number and Jerry's going to
do this you think you know I think
they're in good enough cap position to
do it right now but at some point when
you're paying DeMarcus Lawrence that
money and you have the highest-paid
offensive line and football and Zeke is
gonna want his Todd Gurley contract plus
a little bit Mauri Cooper's about to get
paid I mean at some point somebody's not
going to get paid but I don't think it's
gonna be dak
and I don't know what other situation to
mean your your your in a wind now
situation and you know you can't get on
that everybody once again on that rookie
contract that quarterback contract and
then try to build around them you're not
able to do that anymore with with dak
and other guys that you mentioned here
so I don't know if there's any other if
I'm Dax agent I'm like hey this is what
we want no and I wouldn't buy I'm Dax
agent I'm saying this guy has played for
you know five six hundred thousand a
year for four years and it's time to get
paid and and the big one that where you
get to thirty million uses so much for
me saying he deserves anything close to
Russell Wilson or air Rogers those are
different veteran accomplished
quarterbacks but when Garoppolo is at
twenty seven and a half and Kurt cousins
is a twenty eight are those really more
accomplished guys than dak at this point
who would you rather have that's you
know I said the other day I'm gonna take
back over cousins I would say Garoppolo
over deck although I've barely ever seen
it's because Garoppolo looks like he's a
quarterback out of central casting he
looks he looks great and you learned
from Tom Brady of course you know all of
those great quarterbacks who learned
under Tom Brady and where are those
great quarterbacks here well you're
right the Cowboys tried one of those
with Matt Cassel a few years that words
well let me pose this let's say dak and
the Cowboys had the thirteen and three
season last year would this even be a
story would this be any like when it
seemed like a foregone conclusion that
oh my god you got to wrap him up you
know after that year right no you're
right his best here was his rookie year
yeah
best record thirteen and three four
interceptions that year's sent Cowboys
team records you know four passes
without an interception rarely fact I
think he had twenty five sacks a year
had over fifty sacks last year more
interceptions ten and six is the best
they've gotten to and you know it looks
at time shows deficiencies which some of
his throat no not all of his
throws our bad I mean people exaggerate
that a little bit kind of like Matt Ryan
never overthrows a deep receiver but
yeah his best year was two years ago and
and your that's the thing Jerry talked
about Dax upside and you wonder well he
played four full years at Mississippi
State played 48 games plus playoffs here
how much better and how differ do you
really think he's gonna look at the
future I don't think it's very much
he's Tim countless Sean down this
morning news and around the horn regular
contributor and then you got Jason
Garrett
once again lame-duck coach right right
he's been through that once before he
won that's the other beat the uh whoever
they beat the Lions and lost the Packers
in the playoffs but see last year we you
know and we talked about on this show
he's got to get to the playoffs and win
a game to get a new deal well he got to
the playoffs they beat yeah I don't they
lost to the Rams he didn't so that
apparently wasn't what they were looking
for and now all Jerry says everybody
knows we got to win more games more
appears to be Wow getting to an NFC
Championship for the first time since
1995 yeah I just I wonder if he can
survive this one if if they don't get
deep into the playoffs I I just I don't
know you know I mean Jerry is very paced
weird it feels like he's spontaneous
because he wants it now but then he's
been too patient with his head coaching
situation how do you explain that
dichotomy III can't explain the Jason
Carolyn because you've never been
patient with any other coach it wasn't
even pace with Jimmie Johnson and Jason
Garrett is going into year ten oh my god
and he's won two playoff games but yeah
I had the under with that I did not have
the over with Jason care god well I know
nobody thought you know he was gonna
he's gonna be close to double Jimmie
Johnson in most games coached under
Jerry Jones at the end of this year and
he's very very comfortable with him and
he truly believes that he's a very smart
coach but he talks about like his growth
and one day this is gonna pay off will
win how many years I mean it took Doug
Peterson to I mean how many years to
take Jason Garrett to get to where do
you think he's gonna go you went around
the horn tonight I'm not I'm technically
on vacation this week only doing rare
media period will be the only one nobody
else's ass and you guys were short on
the show days but if I do I have 45
seconds I wanted to say something here
okay
before I bow out I really appreciated
you saying what you had to say about the
pain you've dealt with and depressing it
all and and you know I know from
personal experience how much people
respond to that and how they think we
all live we're on TV we live perfect
dream boat lives nothing could ever be
wrong tomorrow happens to be the tenth
year of sobriety for me the 10th
anniversary awesome and and you had me
on when I when I when the book came out
a few years ago and I still hear from
people who you know I read the book and
it helped me this and that but I know
what you said helped thousands of people
and I thought it was terrific that you
did it I hope you feel all right and I
thank you thank you Tim I feel a whole
lot better now and you know since these
chemo treatments the last couple of
months a whole lot better
I mean I'm shooting hoops I'm on the
golf simulator I could never do that you
know the last couple of years here at
all but you know it's weird it and
people said hey we didn't know you're
going through this and you know I didn't
know you were going through it I was
around you at events but I never looked
at you and said you know Tim's got a
problem or I wouldn't have known that
we're good at disguising stuff if we
want to keeping secrets oh yeah you're
around an alcoholic course I mean
they're great at lying to you and
deceiving you and and you know but I
never knew that I never in them when you
came out and I was like wow I maybe I
should have recognized that I don't know
I wouldn't have said anything but I just
I didn't I didn't realize it at the time
it would have been hard you shouldn't
beat yourself up over that too much
maybe a little beat yourself up a little
well you should meet yourself up a
little bit because you could have said
this on the round the horn if you had
won on the round the horn and say I'd
like to give it a little shout out
that's a good point that's a good point
is Woody Paige said he was going to do
it he just didn't win you can you know
that not happen and next week's is way
too late to pay tribute to me on around
the horn is that getting to ladies I
mean one weeks ago so you know what I
mean we've all moved on from it like mom
the dancers are now making fun of me
well I can see that yeah and I
understand why but we might we might
still squeeze it on there thank you find
a way thank you Tim thank you thank you
for taking time out from your not so
busy day to join us on the print going
to Cabo tomorrow it's well I'll be a
little better than rainy Dallas are you
bringing your girl my girl and my
daughter and her best friend so same
place we went a year ago lot of laying
by the pool of the beach and eating
nachos that sort of things nice send
pictures thank you tip that's a Tim
Keller show around the horn for more Dan
Patrick show tune in to audience channel
239 on Direct TV stream for free on VR
live or download the Dan Patrick show
app